while many of you have received the
vaccine there are still thousands who
have not
and now the state and local health
leaders want to change their strategies
to get more people vaccinated
joe mohler live at the las vegas
convention center a major vaccination
site joe as demand decreases
there will be an increase in pop-up
clinics all around the valley
well brian as you know we've been out
here several times in the past couple
months and i have to say this is the
slowest we have seen it in a while now
it is winding down over here but there
are
still a few cars in the parking lot but
this there wasn't much more throughout
the day
now there's a move to target the hardest
hit areas
inside it's like there's nobody this was
the scene at the las vegas convention
center wednesday
i'm very surprised to see you know how
empty it is i was like well this isn't
going to take me very long
compared that to this a few weeks ago a
packed parking lot
now it is a different story it was in
and out within 15
20 minutes with the waiting period after
the injection
so roughly 43 percent of the state's
population has had at least one shot
as the demand for the vaccine slows down
carissa loper with the nevada division
of public health says they will switch
strategies
we need to start reaching into
communities more
comprehensively including working with
groups like faith leaders
um the mexican consulate
and other community-based organizations
to ensure that nevadans know where and
when they can get vaccinated
come may 5th the cashman vaccination
site will close and pop-up clinics will
open
in terms of the goal i think it's we
want to reach what's going to be herd
immunity and most protective for all
nevadans
this is the perfect time to do it as the
wait times are not as long
i decided to wait push it off and then i
seen there was
more appointments available and i was
like let's do it now
back out here live state health
officials also say in recent weeks they
have noticed a decrease in the amount of
people getting tested they say it's
still important if you are showing
symptoms to contestants to make sure
we are slowing the spread reporting live
at the convention center john muller 8
news now
by the way they're also taking walk-ins
as well if you're not worried about
worried about making an appointment for
those